all right cool
hello
i just measured there's about a five
second lag or so but i can hear chat and
everything is all right
so uh yeah welcome to the first the
first edition of
ml news live stream uh this is out of
necessity uh my editor is on christmas
vacation
and i don't have time to edit myself so
we're just gonna have to do this live uh
it might be a bit slower than you're
used to
and uh a bit more a bit less concise but
i hope you forgive me
uh
yeah hello everyone and and thanks
everyone who is here everyone who's
gonna watch this in the future i will
put all the links to stuff that i
present into the description once the
broadcast is over
and i hope i can leave it up in public
uh not that you know if i say something
stupid i might have to take it down
because that's usually the stuff that
gets edited out
all right so uh first of all first of
all most importantly uh please please
check out weights and biases look at
this awesome uh tea beaker i use it for
tea but you know you might use it first
i don't actually know if they if they
sell it or if they just give it to
people who chill for them in any case uh
check them out i've been if you followed
me on the stream uh you know that i've
been working on a little bit of an
implementation of a question answering
system and uh this is my panel for this
and it's just so easy with weights and
biases it it takes one line not even
like as soon as you're logged in uh it
automatically logs here and this is my
sweep that i'm currently doing
it's just optimizing hyper parameters
for me
i don't have to do anything except sit
and wait and it's optimizing all my
hyper parameters and you can see right
here i can sort of filter by the runs
that did best this is bayesian
optimization i have no clue
how bayesian optimization of hyper
parameters works like in depth but it
just does it for you
you can filter it tells you which
parameters are important here i can see
the learning rates are probably going to
lead to good performance and uh it kind
of just logs everything and then gives
you an idea not you know here's my
training loss but also it logs all the
the system like gpu usage memory usage
blah blah blah whatever you want
and after that you know you can look at
this in in sort of table form you can
filter it and you can look at all the
logs here i've checked them before
there's a lot of errors i might want to
casually check in on that and then
lastly you know i can i can just stop it
from here or pause it or or whatever and
this runs distributed like this runs in
a bunch of servers they just pull the
new experiments they run it and they
report it back super awesome uh yeah
please check out weights and biases
they've been an awesome sponsor
and i'm pretty sure it's good for you
it's completely free for personal use
also some of you might have noticed
merch but it's not done yet
as you can see the logo is kind of way
too far out
so
it sort of
hides under the arm
but this is mo it's mostly it's mostly
for myself uh just because i i think
it's funny to have merch but i will
put it up
if anyone wants one too
but this has to move a little bit closer
to the middle i think and there's a few
other fixes i need to do all right first
story first
this is too funny someone opened a a
an issue on the tensorflow github repo
uh saying i effing hate tensorflow
this is in this is insane um
like just the the audacity of this
person to
open a i mean people sound off on reddit
and and twitter and whatnot and we're
used to that but people are sort of
abusing the the github issue
system in order to sound off on
libraries it's you might have guessed
it's been
met with various different reactions i
think most people say uh this don't do
this please although
this being the sort of first of its kind
at least in our community it is a bit
funny but you know the joke has been
done now so please don't do it again uh
it's not like the first one's funny and
the rest isn't but if you want to see um
this is what it said it said i hate
tensorflow yes i think hey tensorflow i
created this github account only to open
this issue
please use jax or pytorch or anything
else don't use tensorflow
don't report me don't mad don't mad at
me
don't ask me why
because i don't want to talk about it
anymore i effing hate tensor effing flow
and
as you as you might imagine um
people
have
reacted and reacted and then this got
posted on reddit and twitter and then
people reacted some more
and
if if you wanna if you wanna give this a
go it's i think it's funny don't do it
but this was funny um and then obviously
it's been locked the spam as it should
be there is a bit of a
bigger discussion on reddit so
uh
exactly of why people uh hate tensorflow
i have not used tensorflow in quite a
while i have to say at least i haven't
used any like i haven't programmed
anything myself i've used code i've
modified code but if
when i program myself it's usually in
torch uh so people say that tensorflow
has sort of become a big buggy pile of
of of garbage or equivalent
i think software libraries you can
always you can always argue about it and
negative opinions you know as as reddit
is negative opinions will always sort of
bubble to the top and be more prominent
than people who say yeah
it's kind of okay
so i don't know what you think about
tensorflow it's
it does its job and
it's powering a lot of the world's
machine learning and i think it's pretty
easy it's pretty good to get started it
has keras as a high level
abstraction
and
yeah i they put a lot of work into it
and yes there's some bugs but
i just thought i just thought it was it
was quite funny
um if you want to see all the opinions
as i said github is
github is fine enough to record the
history of everything that has been said
right here so feel free
okay
thank you wait
wait
how do i make this go away
the south china morning post writes that
chinese scientists develop an ai
prosecutor that can press its own
charges
uh the machine is able to identify eight
common crimes such as fraud gambling
dangerous driving and picking corals and
prosecutors in china already use an ai
tool to evaluate evidence and assess how
dangerous the suspect is to the public
so this is a story about sort of
advances
in
statistical systems in china in the
criminal justice system and
it is a bit more it is a bit more
nuanced than the title seems to um
suggest so
what
this has also been done in the us there
was big stories about systems that
assess
how likely criminals are to be repeat
offenders
and now this system right here is a
system that apparently is able to
identify charges
so
um
if you look for quarrels these are the
these are the things that it recognizes
credit card fraud running a gambling
operation dangerous driving
international injury sorry intentional
injury
obstructing official duties theft fraud
and picking corals and provoking trouble
so
what it's doing is you input a
description of the case like a verbal
description and it will output the
charges of uh the defendant the charges
that it would charge the defendant with
it is not as far as i understand it is
not the judge it is not uh you know
simply assigning those charges and then
that's it um it is seem it seems to
automate sort of the the most boring
tasks that a prosecutor does namely you
know there's a description there's a
police description and everything and
then the charges to be filed have to be
formalized and i can't imagine look i'm
not trying to i'm not trying to downplay
the severity of this but i can imagine
that for something like someone you know
stealing something from a store uh this
is a very standard procedure right
there's a police report it always looks
the same it kind of lists the things
they stole how they behaved yadda yadda
and the
sort of the mental uh the mental effort
to take that and formally file the
charges you know putting all the crosses
in the right place selecting the right
things from the lists and so on is maybe
uh
you know it's it's straightforward i can
totally see that a statistic like an nlp
system will
uh
simply be able to do this out of the box
now this is not to say that there are
many dangers along with this and many
worries um but
you know that for example it says that
picking quarrels and provoking trouble
is a catch-all charge often used to
stifle descent but
prosecutors do that anyway right the
system simply replicates what the
prosecutors have done in the 17 000
cases in the last five years that it's
been trained on
so you get all the problems of you know
this has been trained on old cases there
are sort of old biases in there and what
not also the machines probably will not
be able to distinguish slight nuances
but you would hope that in a functioning
criminal system this goes before a judge
the judge would
take a look at the charges and what has
been uh what what is being said
so
i mean
you know apart from all of all of what
you can think right here um
i do think that
low-level
sort of
grudging tasks that people have to do
taking natural language putting them
into some sort of formal systems can be
automated by ai and the fact that this
year is being done in the criminal
justice system is is worrying but it's
um
it's sort of more by association than by
what this particular thing seems to be
not saying that there isn't horrible
stuff going on but you know look into it
yourself if you want to find out more
i'll link to it
there is a was a popular very popular
tweet going around by a max wolf saying
i forced a bot to look at every pokemon
and told it to generate its own here are
the results and
the pictures are quite neat it's sort of
pictures of of of new pokemon and they
actually look like some so
given how many pokemon there are isn't
this like the sixth or seventh or eighth
generation of pokemon we're on now i'm
surprised that in the space like in the
latent space of pokemon there is still a
pokemon that doesn't exist it seems like
every combination of pixels that you
know looks like a shape of any kind has
been made into a pokemon so uh like
like how how how does this thing here
not exist this seems like it exists
right uh i don't know but i guess that's
the beauty of that's the beauty of gans
uh yeah so
uh if you if you're interested check it
out it's pretty cool project
next story uh gibson dunn writes new
york city enacts a law restricting the
use of artificial intelligence in
employment decisions
this is a report and apparently from
2023 on new york city employers will be
restricted from using artificial
intelligence machine learning products
in hiring and promotion decisions
and specifically here it says
so it defines automated employment and
decision tools it defines as any
computational process derived from
machine learning statistical modeling
data analytics or artificial
intelligence that issues simplified
output including a score classification
or recommendation
that is used to substantially assist or
replace discretionary decision making
for making employment decisions that
impact natural persons there's a fancy
way of saying if you have some system
where you throw in a bunch of cvs and
you get out like a score of how good an
employee will be
you cannot use these systems anymore
so the law prohibits the use of such
tools to screen a candidate or employee
for an employment decision until unless
it has been subject of a buyer's audit
okay a bias audit is defined as an
impartial evaluation by an independent
author yada yada yada
so
this is
first of all first of all okay first of
all the definition here could cover
nothing and everything okay any
computational process derived from
machine learning statistical modeling
data analytics or artificial
intelligence that issues a simplified
output including the score
classification recommendation yada yada
so what if an what if an hr person
googles a person right like google is
certainly based on statistical modeling
the outputs are a simplified output it's
not you don't get the entire internet
you only get a simplified output
pertaining to the person you search you
get a score in the classification
you know the the search results no one
looks past page one on google and yes hr
people
do use that to substantially assist them
in decision making so
search engines are now banned uh unless
they've undergone a bias audit but this
applies to search engines what if i
throw my throw the cvs into a machine
that simply checks uh for
i don't know
like like some some really exclusion
criteria i have for example if a person
is even permitted to work in the country
that i'm willing to hire well is that an
automated dyadata
um it is
so these definitions are made so they
can cover everything potentially and
then of course there is the back door
okay you have the bias audits and the
bias audits they sound nice but we all
know that they're going to be
you know they're going to be i don't
know as flawed or more flawed than the
original systems and all this is in my
opinion is a shift of money and
resources you can bet that the bias
audit companies are lobbying hard for
this law to be passed
um
you know i'm not
like this is not saying anything against
you know these these systems do have
bias these systems have giant problems
okay
this is not commenting on that this is
commenting on this law it's
it's made such that it covers it can
cover everything and it is made to shift
resources to a thing that in my opinion
doesn't solve any problem at all
with these automated hiring tools of
course they are
tricky right
but we have to face the reality a lot of
places now they they get so many
applications it's it's like impossible
to handle them
humans make mistakes too so now if you
don't want to undergo this bias audit
you have to
get more humans you have to overwork
them more you have to have them more
like hey human check all of these cvs
for who's even eligible right this is a
grudging task and now the humans are
there being like all right you don't you
think they don't make mistakes you think
the humans are not biased well okay
um but that's that's my opinion you can
decide for yourself at least the the
violations are
um moderate let's say
at least for so i guess medium-sized
businesses can afford violate to violate
this
next story this this is actually this is
a bit more uh drastic um there is a
tweet by christine live doll saying my
ten-year-old just asked alexa on her
echo for a challenge and this is what
the what she said i presume that is
referring to alexa um
so the
prompt is telling me a challenge to do
and the responses here is something i
found on the web according to this
website the challenge is simple plug in
a phone charger about halfway into a
wall outlet and then touch a penny to
the espo to the exposed prongs
and there's even a little timer to go
along with this so this naturally
shocked a lot of people well shocked i
mean people deliberately saying well i'm
not shocked i always knew um
but
uh
you know
it is it is a rather a rather grave
suggestion right if someone were to
actually follow this uh there is serious
danger involved right here especially if
you hold on to the penny as you do it
but even if you don't you know things go
bang and start burning
um so
the bigger question is more of you know
what should we do about it of course
amazon responded saying they'd fix it
immediately
but you know obviously there's going to
be other cases the question is a little
bit
is there something you can proactively
do against these types of mistakes
while still retaining the service right
of course we could say we don't do
question answering anymore
the problem here is not that this
challenges exist because
obviously alexa found this on the
internet somewhere this is a challenge
people actually do it's you know akin to
eat this eat this
cleaner this tide pod
it's a little bit like this it's just
something stupid that people challenge
each other to do
and it probably originated from someone
just trolling however
uh if
alexa finds something like this a lot on
the internet uh
you know should it suggest that or what
can we do here
should we
try to detect this should we display a
warning uh do we have to take down
question answering all together so that
people don't get the impression that
this is some authoritative information
it is a hard problem right uh you cannot
possibly cover all the dangerous cases
because
well language is rich and the internet
is good at coming up with new stupid
things so it's impossible to cover all
of them however
you know what else should you do should
you sort of
put on 20 disclaimers well if you put
them everywhere people are just going to
disregard them it's it's the same as you
know you you put with every file you
open you put like this could be a virus
after a while people stop paying
attention
so i'm
not entirely sure
what to be done here and i'm
i i don't know if
the people who are very outraged about
this uh have better ideas but it is a
it's a cool challenge if you are looking
for something to work on with like some
real life benefits if you can get to a
general place where things like these
are prevented
um
then very very
uh you know
excellent work
there is this article by marketwatch
um
this font is driven by artificial
intelligence this sorry this fund driven
by artificial intelligence is ditching
big tech here's what it's doing instead
so this is about a fund like a hedge
fund that is
run by artificial intelligence so the
story is about how it used to have a lot
of the sort of of the five core fang
stocks in it and made some profit but
now recently recently um it has it has
been
um dropping those it only has apple now
so it says
as recently as september
these were its top four positions making
up nearly a quarter of the exchange
traded fund
um now only apple is in the portfolio
so this might lead you to believe wait a
minute there is you know something here
i you know what what is going on this ai
knows something i don't and
ah it's strange and
then you read
it uses ibm watson to pick stocks
me who trusted its money to ibm watson
uh a product that won jeopardy yes good
job you won jeopardy and then failed to
solve any other problem
ever
allegedly allegedly
so uh you know good job trusting your
money to watson i mean if it you know if
it works out good for you uh happy you
get rich off of it but
uh this is this is not financial advice
this is for entertainment purposes only
okay
this here the food recognition benchmark
2022 it's a real life real life not hot
dog okay so
recognize food from images extremely
useful especially distinguishing hot dog
from not hot dog you you can
take part in it uh if if you have a clap
not hot dog not hot and so easy so easy
okay not hot dog now you you wha look at
this
is there even hot dog nah nah
so far
but you know can you build a machine
that does the same like me as a human
who knows
take part in the food recognition uh
benchmark uh there's prizes apparently
there's a drone
there's another drone
i'm not curious i uh i already solved
the challenge
and there's an oculus
yeah you go for it
um yeah this is the helpful helpful
things uh section of the broadcast so
we're gonna go a bit faster now and i'll
just point some stuff out that might be
helpful to you and as i said all the
links are will be in the description
so
uh gradio now has native embeddings so
without iframes there's like these these
like two lines of uh
of code it's actually
it's not two lines of javascript unless
you count the comment i guess it's one
tag and one line of javascript so
you can see this right here this is an
embedded radio space so this
what is it mushroom nah okay let's try
let's try it i only have my mouse right
here so this
wait no clear ah
so this
and then this
and then we're gonna i'm did i ever say
that i am terrible at drawing
syringe no i was going for hot dog um
okay maybe i'll like the bun
and then the
thing in the middle
and then the other bomb
[Laughter]
see we could put this on the on the food
challenge okay you can now embed
gradient spaces very cool um like
natively with javascript active loop is
has developed this hub which is supposed
to be a dataset format for ai this
reminds me of this xkcd comic where they
go
there's 16 different standards
for data transmission let's develop one
that unifies them all and then it's like
six months later there's 17 different
standards for data transmission
it is a common interface for data sets
what i think what i find cool is that it
has lots of back end possibilities so
you can choose sort of where your data
set is stored can be in an s3 bucket in
a google cloud bucket in memory so on
and therefore you can send these around
and
you know give data sets easily to other
people no matter where they are located
it might be it might be something for
you
uh
yeah check it out if you are looking for
a solution like
this echo is a library by the way these
things they are sometimes not super new
but they have new releases and or i've
just recently seen them i
call this news but it's it's more like
news to me
um
echo is a library that visualizes nlp
models and they also have a new
version out now and this is a pretty
cool library so for example here you can
see you can
ask which of the tokens have led to a
particular decision like here the
decision negative is influenced very
much by you know the words like weakness
and expect and
uh blow expected um so you can you can
decide for
you can make better
informed decisions about what your model
does they have lots of visualizations
like
what
you know
what words are considered in particular
instances at which layer of a
transformer did the model you know think
or did the model get most of the
information so you can see here uh the
word london which is the correct token
at layer 0 it was ranked 1444
as a token um so it wasn't really on top
of the list of an answer but then as it
goes through the model it sort of gets
more sure layer 9 seems to be
particularly effective
right here in layer 10 it sort of
broadens its scope again a little bit
but layer 11 actually gets gets it right
[Music]
broadens its scope i guess it puts it at
rank 53
maybe a short hesitation before the
finish line it's interesting um is this
a i wonder is this a general pattern
that sort of the last layers sort of fan
out again i'm not sure because it seems
super monotonic until like layer 9 right
here i'd be interested there is some
evidence from research that
these
transformer models especially bird or so
that have been trained with masked
language modeling they have their more
abstract or their most abstract
representations in the middle somewhere
because towards the end they need to do
do language modeling again and actually
go back to tokens sorry
just uh
double as refreshing
yeah so what are the patterns in neural
activations invert when it process a
piece of text and so on there's lots of
examples of visualizations you can do so
if you look to understand your
your
language models
check out echo
then this is continuum also with a new
release i believe
no this is september 17. it's just news
to me this is a data set library like a
data loader library that you can plug
into
torch data loaders is if i understand
correctly and what it allows you to do
is to do continual learning
so
lifelong learning continual learning and
so on and what is this on the right
usually data sets they're they're sort
of bounded even if you can't load them
in memory uh
all they are usually defined by like a
set of files or or some table in a
database or whatnot and uh with this
library this it extends it a bit more
and enables things like yeah continuous
learning lifelong learning iterated
learning and so on
there is a this reddit post and it's
about a
repository that makes the rounds every
few weeks on reddit and people are
always excited by it and
it's
okay i messed it up it must be coming
somewhere it's the transformers deploy
repository that makes transformers
inference faster and
what it does is it says it somewhere
it says it somewhere what it does is it
goes it parses your python code it
builds the ast the abstract syntax tree
from it and then it's able to
go down the abstract syntax tree and
whenever you have something like a
weight layer
where is it
behind the scene transformer source is
parsed to ast operators like matrix
multiplication or layer norm are wrapped
by a quantizer linear layers are
replaced by quantized versions of them
and some unsupporters unsupported
operators are replaced so this is very
automatic you plug it in and it does as
much as it can for you this is not a
substitution for you writing good code
but it can quite can speed up your
inference a little bit so you can see
here from the example code you have to
wrap your code in a context of this qat
calibrate object and then you can do
various operations on the model
such as yeah this setup model qat will
will auto auto enhance your model let's
say
okay
this was this
facebook has a model called slip which
is a derivative it's a mix between clip
which is we train images and language
together and self-supervised learning if
i understand correctly yes and
self-supervised learning is when you
take images and you
do any of the any of the five million
self-supervised learning tasks usually
it's either some kind of contrastive
objective
where you try to bring representations
close together and far apart or it
doesn't even have negatives in any case
this model beats clip in various
benchmarks various zero shot regimes so
on and shows that you can in fact
combine
the um
the
image language supervision like clip and
self-supervised learning which i guess
they do like they do in sim clr
so this is specifically for for uh image
data
that has text associated with it
all right
there is paper and the models are
available code is available
cool this i i found this um
joel jang has made another music video
to my uh be my weasel song i i just
found that to be fantastic
[Music]
it moves it sort of the the images they
stay they stay quite
um like there's a continuity to them
which tells me that uh maybe
joel optimized the latent representation
always kind of started from the last one
when starting to optimize i initially
always started from a random one then
optimized and then calculated the
trajectory in between them i don't know
if if that is different here but it
looks very cool i didn't i found this by
like accident uh
so
thanks joel very cool and there is a
github repo with the code um where you
can i suppose create your own
um
this is obviously upgrading from my
original design with that had a clip and
a regular gan big again
this is upgraded to now vqgan which is
obviously much much more pretty
if you want to check it out
this is available
and my original repo remains available
and i believe the song itself i linked
somewhere as an mp3 file so yeah
there is uh this library rl hive which
is another library to do reinforcement
learning
the reinforcement learning library space
is like so there's more oral libraries
than rl researchers or
problems to solve however
it also tells you a little bit that
there appear to be a lot of stuff not
solved yet like in library design it's
not like the whole world has converged
on a reinforcement learning library and
this might stay this way because the
field is just so large or it might be
because no one has sort of cracked the
code yet and therefore if you are
unsatisfied with all the url libraries
so far then give rl hive a try
has a neat documentation
with some quick start experiments and it
is easy to run single and multi-agent
reinforcement learning
tasks
compute is a library a general purpose
gpu compute library
and the special thing is that it's cross
vendor so you can see
it's it supports various graphics cards
so this is
it is a bit lower level than
uh you know the frameworks like
tensorflow and and whatnot even if they
they sometimes have as far as i
understand they sometimes have a little
bit of a support uh for
different
other than nvidia gpus for example i
mean
tensorflow has uh
has a tpu support but here we talk about
graphic cards so this is for anyone who
wants to write a little bit of a lower
level code like um
gpu code that maybe does a little bit
more complicated things than just
plugging neural network
layers together
but doesn't want to go super far down
close to the metal and having to contend
with all the different graphic card
vendors which inevitably you end up
writing it for the one you have and then
trying to port it to something else so
i have
not much clue about this stuff
if you're interested in lower level but
yet still abstract uh gpu code then
maybe give compute a try if you have
something neat to implement and you
think you could benefit from
acceleration but the
frameworks uh like tensorflow pytorch
are just to a bit a bit too restrictive
this might be for you
okay the cppe data set the
um
it's a it's a data set that is
essentially an image recognition
localizations segmentation or
multi-sorry
multi-multi-localization data set and
it's specifically for around personal
protective equipment so the difference
here between this and other data sets is
that this is specifically for the niche
of the medical field and they've paid
special attention as far as i can
understand that the the pictures are
real life pictures well on the top left
i'm not entirely sure
how real life that is that this person
is posing but these are not kind of uh
staged let's say these are uh
at least that's what they say in the
paper they they really paid attention
that they're complex scenes
they're kind of real-life scenes and uh
therefore the task is quite hard
so if you're interested give this a try
this was it yeah i i knew i had it open
somewhere the transformers deployed now
it's twice okay
um
the
there's a call out to the first
international symposium on the tsatlin
machine
i hope that's what how one pronounces it
settling machine
this is a symposium about well yes the
tetland machines what is it setling
machine i like if you don't know what it
is it's i this is not going to be enough
time to explain it but essentially it is
a neural like you can imagine it as
a neural network-ish thing but that
doesn't necessarily go with
numbers and vectors but its
fundamental units are propositional
logic so it will try to make sense of
the world by applying propositional
logic rules and sort of coming up with
almost a bit like
program building internal program
building making sense of the world by
building up
symbolic rules and then trying to
compute some output out of it that's not
to say that there are no like numbers in
it uh not to say that
there isn't there isn't
uh vectors in any of this
however it's it is built on
fundamentally different
principles
if this is interesting to you uh check
out wikipedia article if this is still
interesting to you maybe uh check out
the
first symposium
jojo gan is a one-shot face stylization
um system
and
all like the entire reason i wanted to
show this there is a a repo to go along
with it so you can try it out uh there
is a hugging face space there is
you know a nice gif that explains it to
you with famous people however the
reason i'm showing this is to show that
if you put elon musk on something right
now you'll just get like exposure
massive and
i'm going to start to do doing this from
now on just put elon musk on stuff it
used to be it used to be like
it used to be lena in the early days
and then that just kind of got frowned
upon and then it used to be obama you
put obama on anything
and then it used to be i think he used
to be like trump
and
now it's elon so
you know what
there you go if you want fame
go either post elon or post this picture
with the airplane and
the dots the the survivor bias uh
picture
and this is the last story
the guardian writes worried about super
intelligent machines they are already
here
now this i almost dismissed this article
but then i saw who wrote it john
naughton and then i remembered we have
already talked about john naughton
before namely in this article right here
the truth about artificial intelligence
it isn't that honest also by john norton
in which you know i rant a lot about
this uh truthful qa benchmark but i have
never ever seen anyone butcher it so
hard like john naughton of the guardian
it's it's just like if you think that
the benchmark itself and the tweets by
the authors are
you know kind of framed to
to give a false impression the article
here is just outright lie about uh what
the results of this research are it's
just wrong and so i was interested in
this article and it just it's like it
has three paragraphs of ooh people have
been worried about ai machines and
uh it finally comes to this dystopian
fears nick bostrom yada yada and then it
says but for anyone who thinks that
living in a world dominated by super
intelligent machines is a not in my
lifetime prospect here is a salutary
thought we already live in such a world
the ais in questions are called
corporations
they're definitely super intelligent the
collective i
dubbed i have immense health and
resources that
you said machines john machines you just
don't you don't you don't get to switch
the topic okay like
like this is it's not a lie like the
other article but he is is clickbait as
hell like what you just you don't get to
do this machines corporations are not
machines you can make an argument that
corporations are
organisms they're hive minds they have
the life of their own they have power
and possess
goods can trade by themselves and have
their own dynamics which no single human
is uh sort of the master of
but you don't get to call them machines
and you don't get to make an article
about how people are afraid of ais
rising up and then and then
saying it's already here they're called
corporations i mean calm on and then
this doesn't even and then it's like one
such super intelligent machine is called
facebook oh no oh no
ah
what what's the deal with dumping on
facebook i i don't get like i have asked
myself this so much um
like it's facebook seems to be
the like
whatever the worst even though i like i
don't see a difference between facebook
and twitter in terms of
how bad the environment is it's both
like a cesspool of stuff but facebook
youtube also doesn't have with these
people youtube is also like but facebook
is is like super super duper bad i i
don't know why i've not figured out yet
in any case uh sorry no
the super intelligent machines are not
already here and it is also not a funny
thought experiment to
um yeah to think about it all right
this this was it
what the
wtf is a facebook
well yeah the
we should almost call it the facebook
right why would white people just call
it facebook that that's kind of dumb um
yes this was it for the first edition of
ml news live thank you so much for
tuning in and uh let me know how you how
you like live streams because
um for sure like we will edit the news
again because this is just too slow and
too long but in general i enjoyed live
streaming uh quite a bit for you know
doing just doing research and chatting
to people but i might do it on the
second channel by the way there is a
second channel uh it's called yannick
out of distribution um but
yeah i might live stream there some more
check out weights and biases please
uh it's definitely a very cool platform
the absolute best
and i'll see you next time
ciao